so now that the Mario movie is now
officially out on Blu-ray I think now
seems as good a time as I need to talk
about this weird quirk in its music that
is when the soundtrack in particular for
the movie came out folks quickly noticed
how many unused tracks there were and
from that didn't take long for people to
notice that the unused tracks fit
perfectly in spots in the movie where
the licensed music was playing scenes
like the Donkey Kong Kingdom
introduction the training montage and
more all have licensed 80s music playing
over them but there are wonderful
composed tracks in the soundtrack that
are literally perfectly composed for
them
[Applause]
I don't know it just kind of bums me out
knowing how much effort and love the
composer and performers put into
bringing these unused tracks to life
only to be replaced by an arbitrary take
on me but who knows maybe this is just
Peak old man yells at Cloud type
business what do you think